[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
turn down the temperature
it's hot in here you jerks happy Monday
everybody
so let's talk about an important fight
that's just getting started no it's not
Kudlow versus kill Mead and Foxy boxing
but tickets are still available
that didn't land
you can Saudi become the State this year
to pass Universal school choice it's
such a big deal it got Randy Weingarten
to finally wash her hair
today Governor Ron DeSantis signed a
bill which expands the state's education
savings account to all K-12 students
regardless of race income background or
even zip code
um
now that they have school choice
Florida's parents biggest worry will be
that their kids will be eaten by pythons
that wouldn't be a worry for me so the
good news is those funds could be used
for anything from private school tuition
tutoring textbooks homeschooling online
learning special needs therapy and in
Florida Alligator repellent
he as proponents put it it funds
students and not systems which may
finally Force public schools to compete
in something other than best drag queen
Florida is the sixth State Nationwide to
approve such options and of more states
do the same this could reshape the
country but there's still a challenge
it's time parents don't have any
activists do whether it's Graphics sex
and textbooks critical race Theory or
drag queen Story Hour the parents are
always caught off guard they're lied to
that it's not really happening until
they find out their daughter Tammy now
goes by Timmy it's the equation of
activism parents are busy making babies
taking care of babies working to pay off
those babies activists don't have these
pressures I mean have you seen them who
would have babies with that
[Applause]
yes they're homely so it's about free
time and the creeps got a lot of it
that's why they can protest it's not
like they'll be late for work because
owning cats isn't technically work
hmm so they have time to agitate and
indoctrinate you don't fact is the
people who are trying to change your
world they don't even live in it if you
think men have babies you probably don't
have babies
they aren't dealing with daycare or
diapers like parents do or Joe Biden
boom
[Applause]
yeah they love a cheap shot this crowd
that's why I love them
but activists they don't live your life
instead they're what I call issue
squatters they show up on Turf that's
not theirs and they act like they're the
new sheriff in town
activists interfering your kids lives
and do so under the ruse of right to
privacy yeah suddenly grade school
lesson plans are classified as if adults
saying this is our little secret has
ever led to something good
have you seen The Tick Tock videos of
bug-eyed activists boasting about
indoctrinating kids it's not a figment
of your imagination like that dream you
keep having of me windsurfing
but when you shine a light on it they
freak out it's their Golden Rule you
shall not show the world exactly what we
say
because even they know their ideas are
gross and must be hidden from light and
disinfected just like mushrooms or Billy
Baldwin
got to go after that Baldwin now
we're running out of bald ones
not kidding
folks on the left accuse you of
transphobia for simply tweeting there
their Tick Tock videos sorry to complain
about a video you posted getting more
exposure you got to have bigger balls
than a lady swimmer
this is driving me crazy what is it is
it I don't know it's just when they put
the mic on it screws up like by
beautiful collar there we go so
activists have parents over a barrel and
the barrel is simply being apparent you
know parents are crazy they're getting
kids ready for school paying bills
driving minivans wearing horrible jeans
they don't have time to battle angry
joyless activists it's not a fair fight
because the weapon again is time and
parents are just too busy to fight back
so they're the last to know who they're
actually fighting against and activists
don't have to do anything but scream for
wacky causes and because face tattoos
are painful
and after messing with the lives of
others what do these activists say well
mind your own business stay out of ours
yeah creeps wanted to tamper with your
kids growth believe they have a right to
privacy nope they've gone too far in
fact it's a movement that's gone too far
in everything so school choice is no
longer about education but about values
it's not about classes or cafeterias or
teacher to student ratio it's about
indoctrination in the form of gender
politics oppression Theology and guilt
by historical Association
and here's why life doesn't make these
unhappy people so these people have to
make their own and they got to find that
raw material somewhere
[Applause]
she has a news for News and also to
smell things most of the Faulkner focus
and outnumbered Harris
he's inspired millions of women to
embrace the lesbian lifestyle after a
writer and comedian Jamie lissell
the money you spend to see his act
counts as a charitable donation
host of fox Across America Jimmy Fallon
and most of her favorite books are of
matches Fox News contributor captive
Jamie welcome to the show I assume that
there are schools in Alaska right we do
have schools in Alaska I'll be honest
with you I don't know uh where my kids
go to school
um because what happens is I'm not
allowed within 20 yards of the entrance
yes um it's not no no it's not because
I'm like a sexual deviant or anything
it's because my kids don't want to be
seen getting in a minivan yes
in front of their kids yeah
um good for Florida yeah yeah
I love Florida what is the primary
Florida is a it's a great place I feel
like I I've performed there recently it
feels very free well I I love her I
would move to Florida in a minute
Florida you know it's the Sunshine State
yes you guys know I live in Alaska which
is uh Sunshine State and
um
I I'm a huge fan of Flora a lot of gut
fall fans came out I did Naples yeah I
don't know if you've ever been in Naples
I was in Naples yesterday you were not
yes I was because Naples is the great
the late show is at 6 p.m
I swear to God that's fine it's the
greatest thing ever we have we had a
midnight show at nine it doesn't even
make sense
all right well I think you did okay for
now okay why don't you just uh shell the
rest of the jokes for later okay we'll
come back to you all right Harris uh
what do you make of this uh movement
this parents movement it's kind of
exciting okay so if you are a school
that's offering all the things that Flex
to the crowd what will you do when
parents have a choice yeah when they can
walk their education money we're in
Florida this new account that they have
when they can walk that money elsewhere
we're already seeing it in my second
home state because you know I live in
cobalt blue jersey where parents I guess
are next to tariffs they don't actually
call us terrorists yes we just don't
know when any of the meetings are
because right he's changing them up you
know off our calendar so we can't reach
it but in Arizona when I'm home we
already do this we already have School
of Choice the new Democrat Governor
though Katie Hobbs wants to roll back
the clock you know like they roll back
the prices at Walmart yeah that's what
she wants to do with school of choice
but they also have it in Indiana a
republican uh Governor there it's
working it works it puts the pressure on
the schools to keep up with what we need
what kids need to compete on a global
scale yeah that's great it's true you
know Jimmy the way you're dressed you're
kind of like the hip guidance counselor
that everybody warns you're not supposed
to be alone with uh especially in a
freight elevator for some reason people
you know what I love about this jacket
people can't tell if I'm Fox Talent OR I
sell drugs to Fox Talent
if you're wondering is both uh but stick
with me uh I always dial in on this
subject because I have one kid as
everybody knows one kid according to
Maury Povich it is mine and uh you take
it more seriously when he gives you the
other father thing yeah we're only in
this position it's worth acknowledging
that schools and specifically liberals
had education as a monopoly it was a
monopoly for them this was their issue
Republicans never touched it until the
pandemic and we saw just how hard they
were failing our children and you look
no further than look at the tick tock
story from last week how they talked
about like Tick Tock is a danger to kids
because they're following these
Tick-Tock challenges like the Kool-Aid
challenge where a kid runs through a
wooden fence right like Kool-Aid roller
skating into a room right okay Tick Tock
is not the problem that is schools
failing children okay tick tock goes
away tomorrow if your kid runs through a
fence he's stupid do you understand
but
and I gotta tell you
in defense of kids yeah every kid wanted
to be that Kool-Aid guy we used to like
in the garage we'd put stack up boxes
yeah and we'd recreate the commercial
running through it yeah but you'd boxes
you didn't run through a fence I didn't
need Bob boxes that's your personal
problem
stop laughing cat welcome to the show
thank you yeah why is school choice so
scary to the other side that's what I
was trying to think about like the only
reason you'd have a problem with letting
the parents choose what school they want
to go to is that your school sucks yeah
I mean they say like okay what if all
everyone wants to go to this one school
and not everyone wants to go to this
other it's okay so the right thing to do
is to force kids to go to a school
that's not doing a good job it's the
only way to make it better is to give
them some incentive to make it better
that's why everything that's mandatory
and you don't have a choice all of those
things suck there's nothing mandatory
that's fun so I don't think this should
be a controversial thing I mean when I
had chickenpox yeah third grade
uh I did all my work from home for that
week and I finished it in like two hours
so my dad homeschooled me for two years
there you go I think that was happening
and that's why I'm so amazing so yeah
you think um I think that happened on
that happened on a larger scale in the
pandemic where they're actually trying
to seeing what was happening in schools
is this why you're anti-vaxxed what
you want everybody to get chicken pox
but then they stay home and they learn
to be homeschooled brilliant no no I'm
not gonna die back I'm Pro chicken
linked to shingles I also had sugar do
just a little bit fake science yeah it's
still better than the time me and Jamie
got monkey pox
uh Jamie will vouch for this those
comedy condos don't clean themselves
holy hell I don't know what that means I
don't know what that means I wonder if
yes he started it
all right so we gotta move on hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else